so you may have noticed that i've been
hanging out with a lot of olympic
hopefuls if you've been watching the
show uh certainly more than the average
american uh
sorry but it says on the card pause for
laugh so i and one of my favorite people
to sit down with was lolo jones you
might know her as a track and field star
but she's also on the u.s bobsled team
and she's a virgin i found out
still even i mean i i tried my best
let's watch
i am sitting here with oh my goodness
it's lola jones and she is an american
record holder bob sledder and track and
field person for check and field no i'm
gonna just say both oh yeah you merged
both my careers you you merged my best
stats with track with bobsled which made
me seem like an incredible bobsledder
which is awesome donated do you remember
the first thing i said to you last night
it was awkward
the whole conversation's awkward just
like this interview
only the best
do you remember the first question i
said though
oh no i said why are you so tan oh yeah
that's right how could i forget that
because i was like on a roll with these
jokes i know and then you said
i said it's because i'm black
that actually happened
and then you should just replay because
that's that doesn't sound just be like
hey why are you so just replay just do
it now yeah like no one's watching
just that just recreate it yeah recreate
the scene hey are you black no
hmm
hear you dark darker than i have a
really nice tan that's how i say it oh
right okay you have a nice tan
all right thanks it's it's because i'm
blocked yeah i'm sorry
can you wait for me to get the french
line gosh who's who's who's the comedian
yeah you okay sorry oh i also said oh
you're the virgin
yes you did that was awkward too it was
all for you not for me i mean i was like
okay what's the next i mean what are you
more excited about winning the gold or
losing the v
is card your real name
absolutely not what is it my real name
is laurie
it's my mother's name but oh it's
beautiful
gloria's a great man you have this great
rap name lolo but then the only thing
that rhymes with lolo is yolo and rolo
and
lolopalooza you're forgetting one thing
that starts with the h homo
another one that's good too but another
one
homosexual oh whole cupcakes come on man
where's your head ho ho cupcakes yeah
people are calling you a ho-ho
those aren't your friends
you dated a twitter follower how'd that
go
uh which one we talking about here you
did that more than once
so you're just left and right sure i'm
free whatever it's not like they're just
strangers and i haven't gone on a
twitter date in actually a while um and
then um the one i went on was a baseball
player so it's not like he was you know
just not anybody i could find out
information on like
were there a lot of i'm going to get to
home-based jokes
what is your best that's a good like
yeah what is your first base like a firm
well i'm confused though what is third
base i know first is what
that allowed on tv
isn't it good enough to know that you're
the best in your heart do we really need
a medal
i just washed away everything i've
worked for in one sentence i
need to end this interview now well i
want to thank lolo jones lolo you are a
true delight and i wish you the best of
luck at the games this year thank you
for taking the time thank you for having
me
first base
first first lolo base
thanks so much appreciate it
be sure to follow lolo on twitter if
only for the chance to ask her out not a
lot of late night hosts explaining third
base on the air that's that's not common
you